on va faire deux choses on veut une
assemblée plus moderne et on veut une
assemblée plus économe des deniers
publics alors sur la seconde partie il
ya 2200 milliards de dettes en france
2200 milliards c'est considérable
on demande des efforts à tout le monde
d'abord à ceux qui nous écoutent à tous
les français qui ont vu depuis par la
fille des années leurs impôts augmenter
à toutes les entreprises ça dégrade
notre compétitivité à tous les
ministères on voit dans les budgets
successifs qui sont des millions à tous
les maires de france dans les mairies
sont sollicités il faudrait que le
parlement soit le seul endroit en france
où l'on dise non non il n'y a pas de
sujet sur la gestion des deniers publics
il faut pas veillé à manipuler l'argent
public c'est bien vrai que les économies
pour les redonner à l'état
il faut donc à chaque fois qu'on dépense
anneaux soit parce qu on l'investît ça
parce qu on le dépense ça soit fait
c'est vraiment une très grande utilité
et donc c'est le job des questeurs et
florian bacheliers fait ça très bien
je trait au travail avec lui avec
lauriane rossi on est donc 3 rue balay
l'ensemble des dispositions ne dépense
de cette maison j'ai franchement on le
ferait pas vous seul et légitime à venir
et l'opinion publique nous critiquer
voilà le sujet qui me paraît essentielle
et deuxièmement les économies qu'on peut
réaliser c'est pas sur le dos des débuts
de ces pour les redéployer pour une
partie d'entre elles et nous notre
objectif c'est que l'autre partie on
puisse baisser un peu le budget de
l'assemblée je trouve que ça serait avec
l'opinion public français que ce que ce
qu'attendent les français
mais vous savez moi je suis un député
donc je suis élu tous les singles ans et
je rendais compte à mes électeurs et
auront lieu à boulogne billancourt anton
député mes collègues députés m'ont élu
pour un an pour conquest heures je suis
là pour faire ce que je pense devoir
faire si je suis pas là pour suivre le
vent de l'opinion publique le jeune
simon les eaux de pluie les économies ça
veut dire valoriser le travail
parlementaire et là on va rejoindre les
groupes de travail du président françois
de rugy et 2 par contre diminué la
voilure et